rendre hommage à celui sans qui la
maison de fer n'aurait peut-être jamais
existé pour le centenaire de la mort de
Gustave Effel la maison de fer de
poissie célèbre sa mémoire dans une
installation spécialement conçue pour
l'occasion il s'agit d'une installation
qui euh a ouvert ses porte ici le 13
décembre à la Maison de fer donc on a
choisi de rendre hommage à Gustave
Eiffel pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que euh ça la maison de fer a
longtemps été appelé la maison Effel
peut-être à tort puisqu'on la doit
plutôt à l'architecte belge Joseph danli
euh mais on a souhaité rendre hommage à
Gustav ealici parce que les techniques
employées dans ces constructions ces
ponts ces tours et et d'autres
constructions qu'on connaît rappelle le
le mode de construction de la maison de
fer en kit avec donc du fer une armature
au programme de ces quelques jours
d'hommage un film pédagogique retraçant
l'histoire de Gustave Effel et de ses
œuvres à l'image de la Dame de fer dont
l'architecture industrielle a inspiré la
maison de fer on se trouve dans une
maison qui est quand même le fleuron de
de la période industrielle c'est un
chef-d'œuvre de cette période rendre
hommage à Gustav Effel ici c'est assez
naturel et pourtant il a fallu imaginer
une une installation qui soit pas
forcément une exposition de fond avec
énormément de document mais plutôt un
clin d'œil plutôt une une ouverture vers
l'œuvre d'ffelles qui qui ici trouve
évidemment un écho très pertinent
sentant après la mort de Gustave Effel
la maison de fer reste l'un des rares
témoignages de son influence dans les
Yvelines l'installation hommage est à
découvrir jusqu'au 31 janvier 2024